elles sont là elles sont venues
expressément pour doux et oui oui mais
oui oui oui mais las ketchup et las
ketchup
souvenez vous elles sont en exclusivité
avec nous ce soir leur site a été classé
en première place des ventes de 26 pays
ont elles parlent espagnol mais ont
quand même on parlera desquels juste
après vous inquiétez pas si j'avais la
chance d'avoir un animateur c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
quand
catherine a pris
oh là là là
et
[Musique]
hélas
et là bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
amis
[Musique]
les
kita
il ne fait pas non plus
[Musique]
il avancé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
allen
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
[Musique]
je
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah mais
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
oui
la foule est ce que tu as fait avec tous
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors en fait john o alors bon c'est
bien merci
alors ok alors sa robe alignés du mal un
jeu pas mieux la carmen
voilà ma canne mais le csa mais elle
s'appelle ricard mais c'était bien de
placer ou le rappel fille ella ella cet
été et marie-louise 7h07 surtout
lorsqu'elles font maintenant c'est
continuerez à ccao la cgeci guet-apens
tendu à y être aimanté filière entre
paris et maintenant elles sont tournées
à paris et bonne journée
les couche-tard cyril moine est comme
aller à l'essentiel et elle aime
beaucoup dabbagh
tu vois tes bonnes en interne youtube
alors ne sont venus exprès pour nous
sont venus exprès pour nous d'espagne
donc merci à vous franchement
[Applaudissements]